jay winnick author of april 1865
the month that saved america where'd you
get the idea for the book
where'd i get the idea for the book well
you know originally i was
before i wrote april 1865 i was writing
a book on the end of the cold war
and in the process of that i started
doing some research and reading on other
wars just to get
insights and parallels from previous
conflicts
and in the course of that in reading
about the civil war several things
happened firstly i got drawn in
you know i became one of these you know
what you would call a civil war buff
uh secondly it occurred to me in the
process of this that
robert e lee surrenders yet he
surrenders only his army
uh there's still three confederate
armies in the field we'll get to that
later on
five days later lincoln is dead and i
thought you know from my previous life
when i worked in defense and foreign
policy i used to be an advisor to lis
aspen
bill clinton's for secretary of defense
and i had been involved in a number of
civil wars myself
most especially the conflict in cambodia
which i had a great deal of work with
it occurred to me that's a story there
and i wanted to look at that and in fact
nobody really quite looked at it that
way in
in effect what i was asking is the
question of how wars end is every bit as
important as why they start or how
they're fought
put differently far too many civil wars
throughout history and quite badly think
of northern ireland that's going on for
some 200 years think of lebanon rwanda
cambodia
think of the horrors of the middle east
or the balkans today our civil war could
have ended just as badly
with the same terrible tragic
consequences but didn't why
that's the question i wanted to answer
in which i do answer in april 1865.
you were the first person on the ground
after the killing feels in cambodia
not the first person on the ground but i
was on the first person to go back to
cambodia in an official airplane
since actually since a the killing
fields and since we broke off relations
it was really quite a trip we didn't
know who we'd meet with
i had to go meet with the vietnamese the
day before in thailand to make sure that
we wouldn't even be shot down
and we didn't know how long we'd be
there we didn't know what kind of
reception we'd get you couldn't
telephone you certainly couldn't email
you certainly couldn't fax
it was really a black hole black hole
removed from the rest of the world and a
civil war was raging there
literally when we landed and it was a
fascinating trip but one of the things
that this work
in in other foreign civil wars
stimulated me was a real interest
in our civil war what are some of the
other civil wars you've seen up close
yeah i've been to i've been to the civil
war in nicaragua
when during the sandinista period i've
been to the civil war in el salvador and
during that civil war i still vividly
remember being in an armored car
with a lead car in front of us and a
chase car behind us and we had a sort of
garrison of machine guns protecting us
uh because the civil war was so raging
out of control and that was another
civil war i'd been to
i had been to the former yugoslavia as
it just just as it was about to dissolve
and i also saw this sort of dissolution
of the soviet union not quite a civil
war but it has variations of it
and had a fascinating um fascinating
several weeks where i met with
lek valencia uh yarozzelski who was the
the commander
who was the president communist
president of of poland um
uh uh we went through czechoslovakia and
we just went through all of eastern
europe as was dissolving it was really
history at its making
and i felt privileged and excited to be
there and and it also
gave me an enormous pool to draw upon
when i would later sit down to write
this book
what do you do now on a full-time basis
um yeah that's what my father wants to
know
and we were discussing that earlier i
now write full-time i used to be in
government
i worked with the foreign relations
committee the armed services committee i
i advised louis aspen who was the first
secretary of defense for bill clinton
i made a decision when the cold war
ended that i wanted to do something
different i came to washington not to
have a job but to do a job
and when the cold war ended i wanted to
do something sir that would mark that
would challenge me anew
and that became writing and uh the first
book i wrote was about the end of the
cold war it was called on the brink
and then i hit upon this idea for april
1865 and
the last the last four and a half years
that's all i've been doing i get up
every day i have the same schedule i
have the same routine
and i either research or i write and um
and at this point i really couldn't
imagine doing anything else in both
administrations the clinton
administration and the bush
administration
people said to me you've got a lot of
context you know a lot of people you've
got the the
background why don't you go into the
administration and at this point i just
couldn't imagine doing it i love writing
and i hope to continue doing it
there's a you read the acknowledgements
there's a conflict to try to figure out
where you might be coming from
politically one of your
favorite people is stephen solar is a
former democratic congressman
and also this is underwritten by the
bradley foundation which is often known
to underwrite conservatives
help me out on the ideology thing right
well the ideology for april 1865 is
there is no ideology i've been in
washington a long time
i uh you know i'm fairly well connected
in both parties and with people of all
political stripes
uh steve soares is somebody who i worked
with extensively
during the cambodia crisis and i've come
to know him quite well we played tennis
together
and i think the world of him i think
he's a terrific guy and a wonderful
statesman in america
uh the bradley foundation has been
helpful to me in providing additional
research monies
uh it's always a question with authors
do you have enough no matter how much
money you get paid and i got a nice
advance for this but it always runs out
and and they were really very nice and
generous in assisting me
um what's important one point i want to
stress is
is the ideology for this book is nothing
i want to write for all readers i don't
want to turn off
liberals i don't want to turn off consid
conservatives really what i did is i sat
down with kind of a fresh eye and a
fresh vantage point
and i said what's the story and that's
what i set out to do
what do you get in your book that you
don't get in all the other
thousands of books have been written
about abraham lincoln for starters
yeah yeah well well you certainly hit
your nail you hit the nail in the head
there because more books have been
written about the civil war
than any other topic there is except for
the bible and of course when i started
out
everybody said to me well you're not a
civil war historian per se what do you
have to say
and um and and that was kind of the
challenge and i mean indeed it was sort
of heretical that i would take on
a body of literature where so many good
scholars have written so many
wonderful and fine books from james
mcpherson to shelby foote
to gary gallagher and onward yet having
said that
because of my defense and foreign policy
background i think i brought to it a
kind of freshness of i
and a freshness of appreciation and and
this this idea of how wars end being as
every bit as critical as why they start
and how they're fought this was really
one of those few areas that has really
not been mined
extensively with this kind of eye one
other thing i do in april 1865 which is
a little bit different
is i strip away the inevitability of
events so that rather than seeing it
with the comfort of 136 years or 140
years of hindsight
you see the events as they take place
you see the decisions as they see them
you see the turning points as they see
them and you see how easily events could
have just as
just as easily gone one way or gone
another way and it's that kind of
richness of history that i wanted to
bring alive
back in the back on page 376. i'd like
to say i know it by heart but i don't
know i'll read this to you
because i think it it touches on so many
things i want you to talk about right
you do the what if yeah what if this
happened rather than that
what if lee had found an abundance of
food at amelia courthouse
and safely made his way south to link up
with joe johnston
explain that yeah no this is this is one
of the great moments in
in american history and it's fascinating
it's filled with drama the setting
that is taking place is as follows
richmond and petersburg have just fallen
and robert e lee with his with his uh
great army of northern virginia having
bested or eluded every other union
general before them
now is trying to hook down south to meet
up with general joe johnston
another confederate general he has a
one-day leap on the federals on u.s
grant
and his goal at this point is he's going
to hook down south link up with johnston
they will strike out of all people bill
sherman and at that point they will take
to the hills as robert e lee once said
if he can get to the blue ridge
mountains he could continue the war for
another
20 years and and um and far from being
dispirited when petersburg and richmond
fell the men were actually quite elated
their spirit was high their morale was
high
because robert e lee had performed
miracles before and so they believed
once out on the open he could do it
again
that was out in the open where he was
his most aggressive it was out in the
open
where he was his most audacious what was
the timing on this
the timing was this was after april
second it was april 2nd leading until
april april 9th when he was in the last
month you were now last month
in that thank you in the last month in
in the final four weeks
and and yet this retreat is contingent
upon one thing
they need food they leave without food
so they're marching in the heat of the
virginia sun they're marching in the
cool of the virginia nights hour after
hour
after for a day and a half straight and
eventually they come to this small
little sleepy village called amelia
courthouse
it's got it's got spanking white picket
fences and weathered cottages
weather cottage houses and tumbled roses
running over the walks and thousands of
men to send in
and eventually lee himself comes in
there and he let out this loud lust each
year because
this is the moment they've all been
waiting for they're going to find food
they will rest and then they will move
down south and continue this war
lee gets to the train which has the the
food waiting for him 350 000 rations
they open it up and what do they find
they find guns
they find cannon they find questions
they find weapons they find everything
but food they find everything but tea
they find everything but water a mere
administrative mix-up
has threatened to undo this mighty army
of northern virginia
as much as any of the union generals
before them these are the quirks and the
turns of the wheel of history
what if he had decided that honorally
not in surrendering but in fighting on
and on for mother south
with organized guerrilla warfare yeah
it's
this this we should discuss in a little
bit of detail
the month of april 1865 actually starts
out let's not take it in the south but
let's move it into the north for a
second a meeting that abraham lincoln
has with his two top generals u.s grant
and bill sherman he wants to talk about
the war when it will end
what will happen how will it happen and
one of the first things he says to grant
is he says you know must more blood be
shed muster be a final bloody armageddon
and of course picture lincoln for a
second just imagine it in your mind's
eye
he is so exhausted and worn by this
ongoing tornado and wreckage of war
he is 30 pounds underweight his hands
are routinely cold and clammy
he is so sick of this ongoing war he has
recently held a cabinet meeting from his
bed
so he says to grant much more blood be
shed grant shakes his head sadly and
says lee being lee
robert e lee the commanding general of
the confederate armies being lee
more blood will be shed and then lincoln
talks about his other great fear that is
haunting him he says
i he worries about them taking the
confederates taking off into the hills
with their hearty horses and hearty men
in other words guerrilla warfare that
was the option that laid before the
confederates and that's what
that's what lincoln feared that's what
grant feared it's what sherman feared
and of course when lee was about to be
surrounded he was surrounded in the
north
south and east and west every direction
but north it's at that point where he
convened a council
of war and in this council of war one of
his top aides ep
or e.p alexander one of his most trusted
aides i should say
says you know we can take to the hills
like partridges and rabbits and a little
more bloodshed now
will make no difference in other words
what he is talking about is he was
talking about guerrilla warfare
he is talking about what jefferson davis
the confederate president was calling
for
guerrilla and partisan warfare in other
words what he was talking about in
effect was the vietnamization of america
and this was a decision that lay before
robert e lee
what if lee had responded to surrender
not with dignity and honor but with rage
yeah yeah it's um it's fascinating you
know where
we're speaking in the year 2001 and
while
i don't want to date ourselves the fact
is if we look at the middle east
there these conflicts are kind of
spiraling out of control
and with every act of violence it seems
to beget more violence
and of course in in the case of robert e
lee he was the moral
conscience of the south he was as
general wise one of the
one of his top men once said to him and
wise was also a former
governor of virginia uh near the end of
the war they were talking about what
will happen next
and um and and wise had ridden through
the lines he dismounted his horse and
he'd actually fallen in
in virginia quicksand and he was caked
with red mud and he looked kind of
ridiculous
well they joked a bit and but then they
talked about the end of the war
and lisa raises this dreaded concept of
surrender and he says what will the
country think
and why is looks over to lee and he says
country my god man you are the country
to these men
so in other words lee was the country to
the southerners and
whether or not he would decide to deal
with the northerners with honor and
dignity
and to become good citizens again or
with rage and continued civil war and
civil violence
he would be the determinant of that
that's what i'm talking about there
or if grant and sherman
had neglected lincoln's admonitions at
city point and responded not with
generosity of spirit but with unbridled
anger
where is city point and when was uh
abraham lincoln there
yeah yeah city city point is um is in
virginia and it's where
u.s grant the commanding general of the
union armies where he had his floating
his floating fortress city camp was in
effect an armed
command post for the northern army as
they were encircling the
lee's army in in petersburg and richmond
and they met on march 27th and march
28th
where lincoln actually wanted to see the
front lines and confer with his
commanding generals
and it was from city point that that
lincoln in the same meeting that he
he talks about his fears of guerrilla
warfare and the same meeting where he
talks about
his fear that this there will be a final
bloody armageddon he does something
quite unique
abraham lincoln says he says when this
war is over
there must be no hangings there must be
no bloody work
and of course what is what is sort of
looming large in his mind
is the specter of the french revolution
because it wound large in the minds of
all americans and of course
to remind our listeners and our viewers
here in the french revolution the
revolutionaries started out with the
best of intentions
and before everybody knew it they were
guillotining the opposition
and before everybody knew it they were
guillotining each other and before
everybody knew it would engulf all the
continent
and in effect what lincoln was saying is
there must be no french revolution here
it was prescient and it was visionary it
was one of lincoln's finest acts and
finest moments
and grant would carry it out brilliantly
at appomattox during the surrender
where rather than treating treating lee
like a defeated dishonored foe he would
treat him with great dignity and grace
and it would be one of the most poignant
scenes really in our history
we're in washington dc if you had to go
to appomattox how would you get there
from here
uh you let my wife drive you no you you
would i mean i can't tell you the exact
highway but it's about three and a half
hours from washington dc
and appomattox is one of these sleepy
little places that does not get nearly
enough attention but it is well worth
going because it's an average
state in virginia i'm sorry mathematics
and
and the best way to do it is really you
can go to richmond first and you can
actually do a little tour of richmond
you can sort of recreate the burning of
richmond has happened on april 2nd and
april 3rd in 1865.
and from there you can go down to cold
harbor and you can see the the the
grassley fighting of 1864.
and then you can actually do lee's
retreat and they have it marked out in
virginia
and and i did it i mean i did it with my
wife we drove it we walked those fields
we walked those roads we actually sort
of did it on the day that we did it
and and people can do it now and it's
it's just wonderful i mean you really
are transported back in time and it's a
trip well worth taking
back to the what ifs or if there had not
been an honorable stacking of arms
and mutual salute to set the tone for
the end of the war
but hangings and humiliation yeah yeah
this is one of the crossroads
throughout throughout history far too
many civil wars end with that sort of
bloodshed whether
with hangings or killings or beheadings
in fact
just think about it the morning that
that lee has made this fateful decision
that he's going to surrender and at that
point he starts straightens himself up
and he says and now i must go meet
general grant
and i'd rather die a thousand deaths
than do that history has more often than
not telescoped and simplified what
happens
they have simplified it to say that
there is lee's vein quixotic retreat
they've said then there's the dignity of
appomattox end of war end of story
in truth it's far richer let's ask the
first question how would he be treated
when he goes to meet us grant
he didn't know what what we do know is
lee that morning
was actually quite nervous
uncharacteristically so he was speaking
and mumbled half sentences
and well he should have been nervous
because because throughout history as he
knew all too well
defeated generals and revolutionaries
and traders were typically beheaded
or they were hung or they were
imprisoned or like the general napoleon
they were exiled
and and in fact that very morning that
very morning the chicago tribune
editorialized
hang li and just days earlier in the
union capital of washington dc
andrew johnson the vice president of the
union went out with several senators and
before a thronging crowd of hundreds
maybe over a thousand
and gave a rousing speech in which he
said we must hang davis we must hang lee
we must hang them 20 times so in fact we
didn't know what to expect
and that grant would treat him with such
tenderness and
dignity and it's such a rich scene
he was carrying out lincoln's vision at
city point of nobody work no hangings
but it was really unique in the chain of
history i i have i was talking about
your book
some friends the other day and somebody
said well lee and um
uh grant knew each other well at west
point
well you addressed this in the book yeah
yeah they they didn't know each other
well at west point
but what is interesting is is the sort
of bonds that are forged
forged in war and and let me sort of set
the scene for a second um
uh to explain this let's go to the
wilderness for a second because this is
where the wilderness is the six six-week
campaign
in 1864 before they begin the siege
in richmond and petersburg and it's
where lee and grant squared off for the
first time
in the first two days of the wilderness
grant loses 17
500 men he goes into his tent at night
and he weeps like a baby
and the next morning when he comes out
everybody expects him to do what every
other union general had done
retreat memorably grant says we will
fight it out if it takes all summer
of course it will take all year just a
few weeks later
at cold harbor in the first nine minutes
alone
grant will lose 10 000 men that is twice
as many men
who will die of all the confederates in
the entirety of the gettysburg conflict
and and he does it within 10 minutes and
in his entire six-week skirmish
grant will lose as many men as lee has
in his entire army and he will lose as
many men as we will lose in the entirety
of the vietnam war
so out of this ghastly warfare this this
bloody
battling uh the irony is that these two
men came to respect each other to
almost to fear each other and to admire
each other and that's the difference in
age
the difference in age is is lee is about
58
and grant is is i think 43. so they
didn't even come close at west
they didn't even come close to west
point but interestingly enough when they
first walk into appomattox courthouse
lee is wearing his finest uniform
because as he said and now he must
become general grant's prisoner that day
and grant who keeps him waiting for 30
minutes comes in in a mud spattered
private spouse in fact later on in
history he will apologize for how he's
attired and you know picture the scene
for a second a small little home wilbur
mclean house
in appomattox courthouse is a little
village of about eight structures or so
in rolling hills
and outside these rolling hills are
thousands of men who are standing at
wrapped attention
to watch this amazing piece of
historical theater to take place
in fact you know when the surrender is
over i'm going to digress for a second
everything will be ripped apart from the
wilbur mcqueen house that the desks the
pens the floorboards the
the wallpaper even a tree that lee
himself would have leaned against that
morning
will be ripped apart so there's nothing
except for a hole there because
everybody knew that day that history was
taking place
and they wanted a piece of it and so
they were standing it wrapped at
attention but inside in a small little
this small little home uh grant comes in
and you know rather than talking about
the surrender they talk about the old
days and i think this is what your
friends are referring to because grant
says you know i remember you from the
mexican war
and what does we do well he looks at him
and he says
you know all these times in this battle
i've tried to recall your face
i could never quite do it and in fact
they continue to chat happily
and and grant tells us that that they
continued on and on and it was
eventually lee who says
i suppose we must discuss the object at
hand the surrender
so though they didn't know each other
that kind of bond the bonds that
were forged and the closeness they had
almost defies the fact that they were
the greatest of nemesis one could
imagine
back to the what is what if andrew
johnson
had been assassinated after all and the
blade hadn't missed
its mark of sewage jugular yeah yeah
let's let's set the stage for a second
the first thing to remember is that on
april 9 as we were discussing
robert e lee surrenders to u.s grant
this dignified honorable surrender
yet he only surrenders his army there
are still three confederate armies in
the field
there are over 175 000 men their
murderous gun barrels hot to the bitter
end
there is jefferson davis the confederate
president calling for
guerrilla warfare and and even mary lee
robert e lee's wife mary lee who is
directly descended from martha
washington
the great granddaughter and by by
marriage of course to george washington
she says robert e lee is not the
confederacy richmond is not the
confederacy
that's how volatile the still the
situation still is and of course as
lincoln feared how much longer would the
war last a week
three weeks three months six months was
lincoln new and feared throughout
history
such time spent had been enough to start
fight and win wars
to unseat great dynasties or to
complicate the reconciliation to come
and five days later lincoln is dead he
gets killed in
april 14th at 10 14 at night and william
seward the union secretary of state is
stabbed
five times his wife is soon screaming
they murdered my son they've murdered my
husband
and only andrew johnson escapes unskates
but the irony of that night is
is andrew johnson was invited to all of
all places ford's theater
he turns it down saying you know i'm
tired i want to have a quiet little
supper and then turn
in and he does this and not realizing
that on the very floor
above him in his hotel is another deadly
assassin who's going to punch a knife
into his heart
but at the last second the assassin gets
cold feet and so johnson escapes
but had johnson been assassinated that
night there would have been a completed
decapitation of the union government
for those who are old enough to remember
that the horror and the trauma
of just kennedy getting killed in one of
the most established
and oldest and most foreign democracy in
the world
imagine this the first ever
assassination of a president in american
history
the secretary of state's been stabbed
five times and
the vice president was also a mark i
just saw
the the the knife it's on display
in fort wayne at the lincoln museum
there and it's on you know it's
headed on loan they're having an
assassination exhibit
and it's interesting all these years
later that knife is still
intact what was that all about five
times the secretary of state was
stabbed by whom yeah yeah his name was
lewis powell and he went by a number of
aliases from lewis payne to a number of
other names
and he was a big hulking man who wears a
broad hat
and and the setting of that night was
was
louis powell was dispatched by john
wilkes booth who who of course is the
murderer of abraham lincoln that the
same night
and at the same time and powell arrives
at the union secretary of state's house
knocks on the door and he pretends to be
carrying carrying medicine
for for the secretary of state seward
and the reason why that is a seward had
just been in a
excuse me a horse accident i mean like a
carriage accident he had he had been
knocked out
and he was in a neck brace lying down
and so the
irony is is that when when powell went
through the house
and was stabbing one person after
another and finally finds the ailing
secretary of state
he stabs him once twice in three and
then five times
what we know or what is clear is he
stabbed a number of times the neck brace
and that is the only reason why seward
wasn't killed
what did you do to get a grip on the
whole story of the assassination
forge theater and john wilkes booth how
did you learn it yeah yeah
um i learned it the way i learned
everything else a couple of ways firstly
there's
a rich body of literature out there
and and i tried to become as as
acquainted and as as
as intimately uh knowledgeable at about
this body of literature as possible
a number of many good books and i
hesitate to name them for fear of
omitting several good ones
secondly i went to the places i went to
the places and again i tried to recreate
it
i went to ford's you know for example in
ford's theater
they talk about how john wilkes booth
after he's
shot after he shot um abraham lincoln
he sort of jumped from the the balcony
and he screamed you know six semper
tyrannus or death to tyrants
and um and it's often said that that was
an easy jump
especially for an athletic man like
booth well i took a look at that
that um that balcony and i played tennis
and i've played a number of sports it
was clear to me there was anything but
an easy jump
so in other words actually going in as
we used to say in the defense business
to actually go out and kick the tires
and to try to relive it to try to sort
of feel it um that's
that was very important and crucial for
me to get a sense of that night
and just the way i did in richmond when
i tried to recreate the burning of
richmond
i really tried to kind of walk the
streets and follow the same paths to get
a feel for
what it must have been like you know for
example at one point
john wilkes booth will cross a
significant body of water well it sounds
pretty easy unless you actually go try
and do it yourself
and you know if you try to also sort of
be on the hunt the whole time
um so i really tried to capture that as
much as i could
the four-seater just ten blocks from
where we're sitting right across the
street the peterson house
you also recreate that whole night he
died would you say 7 22 the next morning
did you find anything new or you just
try to tell the story as you found it
other places yeah
you know it's some of the details that i
use i think are different and that's not
to say i found anything new but i just
sort of saw a new some of the details
that have already been out there
but again i want to go back to one of
the original things i started out by
saying
what i do in april 1865 is i strip away
the inevitability of events
more often than not when you when you
have books on the assassination of
abraham lincoln
it's totally separate from the story of
the end of the war
so in fact most people don't realize
that lincoln was assassinated just five
days after the surrender of lee
and most people also don't realize there
was still three confederate armies out
in the field that guerrilla war was a
real possibility
and that all sorts of things could have
happened to complicate the
reconciliation
one other thing that really struck me uh
that night in the peterson house when
link when lincoln lay dying is um you
know we've been hearing a lot these days
about alexander hague
during the attempted assassination of
ronald reagan saying i'm in control here
and how that was seen as a really rogue
act well on the night of
of of april 14th and then april 15th
when lincoln had died
from this small small little room in the
center of the peterson house
the secretary of war for the union edwin
stanton was literally running the
country he had become the president the
vice president the secretary of war the
secretary of state
and the comforter in chief all wrapped
into one and um
and it shows you just how different the
world they inhabited it was from ours
what did you learn about mary todd
lincoln and her reaction to the
assassination yeah
i mean i mean i have to say that it
really sort of
struck a chord of both poignancy and
pathos in me
because you know her husband has just
been shot i mean his bra
his brains have essentially been blown
out before her eyes
and that night she was weeping and
wailing by his side
and at one point again to show the power
of edwin stanton the secretary
of war she had so gotten out of hand at
one juncture
he screams take that woman out of there
and you know you can imagine this
happening with hillary clinton it would
never happen
but in fact she was actually removed to
the front room of the peterson house
where she continued to weep and whale
and it was only it was only then again
around 7 19 or 7 17
thereabouts when she was allowed to be
back with her husband and she was
screaming
oh do not what what have you done to
take him from me god
or bring teddy to him you know abe loves
him so i mean it had to have been such a
a poignant night back to the what ifs
you've got two left here
and it follows on this discussion what
if after the assassination of lincoln
all
went to pieces and the presidential
transition process fell prey to
momentary passions and fears
yeah yeah i mean you know i went to yale
i got a ba from yale a master's from the
london school of economics and a phd
from yale university again
and i figured that the transition
mechanism vice president becoming
president was all very simple and laid
out that the president dies
vice president becomes president end of
story
in fact the picture was far murkier and
far more complex
in april 1865 because as it turns out
when i went to go check this question
the founders did not intend for the vice
president to become president
they only intended for the vice
president to temporarily act as
president
until there was an election and at that
point then there would be a new
president and so in that fateful evening
when when when lincoln was shot and
steward was ailing with five wounds and
johnson who nobody ever expected to be
president and who had met with abraham
lincoln only once
by happenstance on the day of the
assassination for 30 minutes ever
yeah uh no no no during during just
doing it for the second time
before that right right but not well um
and and we've to this day we still don't
know what they talked about
and and johnson was widely written off
as a buffoon in washington circles in
fact during the
second inaugural the attorney general
while
johnson was kind of rambling on and on
because he was drunk that night
the attorney general said take that
deranged man out of there that's how
low regard how little regard they held
andrew johnson in
and so that evening the temptations for
a regency
or for a cabinet-style government in
fact as i was saying earlier edwin
stanton was basically running things for
the first day and a half
for regency or kavanaugh style
government were great or for that matter
for a military-style intervention you
know after the assassination of lincoln
there would be such turmoil such chaos
and anarchy
gripping the union capital in fact the
new york times would editorialize
if this were france all the country
would be in bloody revolution by
24 hours they weren't such turmoil that
the union cabinet would soon be
discussing
whether or not in effect a napoleonic
coup was underway
and who did they think was behind it
none other than one of their greatest
generals
bill sherman and that's why i think it's
so important to go back and kind of
recreate the world not as we see it
with hindsight but as they saw it so we
can see the turning points that they
confronted
last what if if joe johnston
had not decided to disobey jefferson
davis's orders who was joe johnston yeah
joe johnston was the other
principal confederate commander in the
field beyond robert e lee
so after lee surrendered joe johnson was
still out there and johnston and sherman
had been engaged in 10 days of extensive
negotiations
about what was to come next and
jefferson davis the confederate
president sent orders to johnston
in which he basically said fight on
imagine those words ringing like a
claxton in his head
but johnson's final actions were not to
do what to do what davis said
but his final act is really an act of
disobedience he said no
and he concluded a surrender there
following lee's example
and and by doing that he played a great
role in sort of helping heal the country
but the irony is his last act was not as
a good military man but was really
defying his own confederate president
on the back of your book uh there are
endorsements yeah
how did you get the following people to
endorse this book
doris kearns goodwin james macpherson
paul johnson doug brinkley
gary gallagher and robert daley yeah
well it's a pretty diverse cross-section
of of people
and um you know if you think about
you know you have doris kearns goodwin a
pulitzer prize winner obviously james
mcpherson who i didn't know
um and you know paul johnson we're
getting back to the ideological question
there's kind of an ideological spectrum
there
basically we sent the book to all of
them and we sent it not in the finished
manuscript but in typewritten manuscript
so
it was these people were awfully nice to
have waded through this this typewritten
manuscript and
um uh to be honest i went to the people
who i thought were the very best and who
i most admired
as much as anyone whether it's doris
kearns goodwin or mcpherson or paul
johnson you know and bob dalek is all i
mean gary gallagher and
and i mean they're just all terrific
people and and i just was really touched
that they
had those kind words to say about the
book when did you get out of yale
i was originally class of 1979 i
graduated in 1980
and got my phd actually much later in
1993. where did you go
right after yale after yale i you know i
didn't want to be a lawyer
that was the only thing i knew is i
didn't want to be a lawyer and i sort of
wanted this
you know back in those days it was
foreign policy the great issue of the
cold war that was
one of the hot things to do and i was
interested in that i went to the london
school of economics got my masters in
international relations
and um and it sort of opened up a whole
new world for me and then where did you
start working in washington
yeah i started basically working in
washington in about 1984 85 when les
aspen
uh the democratic congressman became
chairman of the house armed services
committee
he uh he and i sort of knew each other
i'd been writing some pop-eds in the new
york times the wall street journal and
we knew each other that way
and he said why don't you come down work
for me and i was sort of a young kid i
was kind of fresh and green and not very
schooled in the ways of washington
but i got a quick baptism and fire by
becoming one of his his closest aides
on his congressional staff on the on the
house arms services committee staff
and i mean i did everything from writing
speeches to um to
doing analyses of u.s soviet relations
to
uh to assessments of arms control and
all the rest
and and that's really what i did for a
number of years until about 1990 and
that's when i decided
or 1991 and that's when i decided to
take up writing
first book this is my second book what
was your first book my first book was
called on the brink it was about the end
of the cold war how did it do
um it got a lot of attention got a lot
of critical acclaim
ruffled a few feathers um but it didn't
do nearly as well as this
why did it ruffle a few feathers it it
ruffled a few feathers because
ultimately i came out and i said that
ronald reagan will go down in history
as one of the predominant presidents and
was was was really instrumental in
in um in the end of the cold war and and
and my view was is that reagan was a
more sophisticated more nuanced leader
and
you know it took me four years to get to
that point and when i started writing
the book the last thing i wanted to do
was go and say ronald reagan
uh was a critical factor in all this but
by the end of the book
i just felt that that's really where the
evidence went and i actually kind of was
furiously rewriting things to suggest
that
that history will be much more kind and
much more generous to him
and um but because the book was written
fairly recently
after the end of the cold war partisan
passions are still high and
you know just as if you had written a
book about franklin roosevelt shortly
after world war
ii uh it would have ruffled a lot of
feathers i mean that's what happens when
people who are still part of that
those administrations are around history
usually sorts those things out
and i took my first crack at history
there when did you start this when did
you start your research
can you remember a moment where you said
april 1865
yeah where i said april 1865.
that was that's the what the book was
about yeah
i think really going into the proposal
writing process i
i wanted to i mean i sort of focused on
the idea of this april 1865 but i wasn't
sure
the meaning of it the extent of it or
the richness of it
and in one of the things that's clear to
me now having written two books and
especially after writing april 1865
is what you think you're going to say
going into the book will be very
different from what you eventually
come out saying i mean there are a
number of moments during the book where
you really get hit with an epiphany
epiphany and things start rushing
together and you say this is very
different from what i thought
i want to capture this so when did you
begin to
focus on exactly what you were going to
conclude yeah um
and what did you go through to get there
i mean you mentioned going to the ford's
theater and down to richmond and
battlefields right right right it
i mean sort of midway through the book i
was writing the story
and and midway through the book and and
i started writing this and about
you know it the last four years i've
been writing it the first two years was
research and writing
somewhere around year two things started
coming together to me
and the way i write is i don't hand in
drafts to the the publisher
and i'm sort of putting them on notice
for my next book um
what i do is i write the entire book and
then i actually sit down with my wife my
wife
lyric winnick she's also a talented
writer and author in her own right
and we edit this thing at great length
every single paragraph every single
sentence every single word has been
edited and and and pruned in here and
and i think it's important for
a writer to sort of write so people feel
like this is an enjoyable experience
that it reads well that it sort of comes
alive that's evocative
and um and that's that's what that's
what i really labored to do with the
good assistance with my wife lyric
and and that that process takes at least
about six months
but i think it really pays dividends i
don't know how many people have come up
to me and they said they've read this
book they've got tears in their eyes
it's really moved them and um and it
reads like a novel
and i think that's because i put so much
effort into sort of giving that that
kind of aura and feeling
when did you know you're you went on the
new york times bestseller list
when did you know that you had a winner
here yeah um
you know anyone who writes a book who
thinks this thing is kind of
gamed out is just it's not the world
that i live in because anything can
happen
every time the book was read it came
back with the same response so when did
i
i always felt i had a winner from from
really day one once the book was done i
felt there was nothing more i could do
my goal was always to write the best
book i could and then it's up to the
rest
it's up to the rest of the world and i
felt i wrote the best book i could
but from the time that doris kearns
goodwin said that you know this is a
superb piece of history and i'm a
remarkable
you know i'm a marvelous storyteller
with a remarkable tale to tell that what
paul johnson said
uh pw gave it a starred review and they
said it
publishers weekly gave it a starter
review saying this book is a triumph and
that i'm a master storyteller
and and then it just kind of continued
on there but you know even peter
jennings
i don't know if i should be saying this
on tv peter jennings heard me in npr
and he said he wept uh hearing me talk
about the book
and then he said he started he was
reading and he just called me up as a
fan and i was i was very touched by that
what are they weeping about i think
they're weeping about
how how for example people like robert e
lee
uh you know that that men can be on what
we deem now as the wrong side and you
can have such
character and dignity and and sort of
hope against hope rather than giving
it to the passions of the day that they
can really uh that that they can sort of
give of themselves in a sense
let me give you a quick example of that
you know after the end of the war
um you know the south wasn't the south
was in tatters it was a defeated ruined
country
and of course the institution of slavery
was turned upside down
and was gone and there's this poignant
scene that takes place in saint paul's
church
saint paul's church is in richmond you
can go there today it's a beautiful
church i've actually been to a wedding
there for one of my wife's
closer friends and um
and and the charles minogue the the
director was giving the
was giving the the um sermon and at a
certain point it came time for communion
quite unexpectedly shattering years of
tradition a black man walks up to the to
the chancery rail
and he kneels down ready to take
communion and at this point everybody
tenses
they're wondering my god this has never
happened certainly not in the church of
the elite
and and all of a sudden quite
unexpectedly
a man who has his hair is kind of
thinned on top and he's got a mid
level there and and he looks sort of
tired and beaten and worn down and he
sort of slowly walks up and this is a
man who
who just days earlier said i am defeated
i am homeless and penniless i have
nothing left to live for
and that man knelt down to take
communion next to this black man
setting tone for what would come for
what should come next in the south and
that of course is robert e lee
that was a poignant scene there's
another scene that and i've talked about
it before with other authors but it's
still every time you read it can't
believe it happened
the mcclellan lincoln
visit right right and it defies
imagination
explain that whole story well i assume
you're talking about when when abraham
lincoln comes to mcclellan's house
and he wants to talk about the progress
of war and lincoln's time of the war
raises
1860 he was still in charge it said
because he had 18 yeah quit and then ran
against him yeah
it doesn't matter so much yeah but it
was it was not the end right right no
it's in the earlier stages of the war
and and abraham lincoln comes in with
his secretary of state
and and he wants to meet with the meet
with general mclellan
mcclellan mcclellan comes in walks up
the stairs
and lincoln has kept waiting for a full
hour and after a full hour
mcclellan sends a word down to lincoln
he won't meet with him he'll meet with
him the next day
that is unthinkable in this day and age
with a president and a commanding
general
and what it tells us is is it tells us
that the kind of stature that lincoln
had
you know we revere lincoln i mean i know
i revere lincoln and i love lincoln and
he's
he's so crucial to this country but in
his day and age he was as hated as he
was loved
and if he walked into a room he wouldn't
sort of feel it the way
presidents do today and uh one other
little footnote you know the night that
he went to
ford's theater he invited 13 separate
people to come with him and they turned
him down
this was the man who was the president
of the surrender of appomattox
and somehow 13 people turned him down
imagine it happening with a john f
kennedy
or with a with a bill clinton or whether
ronald reagan it'd be unthinkable
you use words with all three principles
grant lincoln lee
anxiety depression and fatigue and how
many times i read it they were
exhausted beyond all belief uh
what did you pick up about that and why
what's with all the anxiety and the fee
not not that they couldn't have it
what did you learn about that yeah yeah
well you learn about it
it's it's war is serious business you
know in
in in in grant's case let's take that
for example i mean grant
just before appomattox um grant had
had this pounding headache this migraine
headache and he was using mustard
plasters and all sorts of other
homeopathic remedies to to take care of
it and
and um and he was ailing he was ailing
it was only when he got word
of that lee would surrender and he said
quite by magic
it was gone the headache was gone and i
mean that the stress and the
terrors and the difficulties of war were
just great you know in in
in least in lee's case he had a bad back
he had diarrhea
he may have even suffered a heart attack
mid in the war and somehow throughout
all this
these men kept pushing themselves they
didn't have fancy hospitals to go to
where fancy doctors
somehow they pushed their bodies to the
limit and of course in lincoln's case as
i was saying earlier
his hands were clammy he was 30 pounds
underweight he was he was
routinely sick the stresses of the war
were so great and
let me let's give a way to think about
this any general who has to send men to
their debts and waves a thousand after
thousands after thousands
have to has this cornell of remorse
eating away at them
and so abraham lincoln and so robert
eagley and so us grant
had to have this cornell of remorse
eating away at them for for what was
going
for what was taking place what was the
total number of dead at the end of the
civil war 620 000
casualties i mean it just it dwarfs any
other conflict in
in our history it's unfathomable at the
end
uh you do something different you
talk about a lot of people and i wrote
all their names down in their ages
that they were at the end of civil war
yeah thank you for picking up on us
well i did henry ford was two yeah
frank woolworth 13. uh richard sears
two thomas edison 18. alexander graham
bell 18.
samuel gompers 15 john d rockefeller 26
andrew
carnegie 30 henry clay frick 16
frederick
remington four and then you have hiram
revels
of mississippi was in in 18
he turned out to be the in 1870 the
first united states senator
of black uh the black race pt barnum was
55
he's 55 at the end of the war yeah and
he he hadn't started
his circus yet he had all these other
these other
other careers and his his greatest
career was still ahead of him
why did you do that what was your point
on that well well you know earlier we
had talked about sort of epiphanies or
things that come to you in the process
of writing
and this was really one of them
somewhere in the process of writing
april 1865 i decided
i wanted to write a snapshot of america
and also the men who would go on to
shape america for the next 20 50 75
years
and so wherever they were whatever they
were doing i just wanted to capture them
and this you've just read the list of a
number of the people who i serve right
where they were and what they were doing
and what really so struck me about all
this is that more often than not most of
them were failures in life and
considered to be failures
you know and with henry ford i talk
about how his father says
oh henry's not much of anything he's a
tinkerer his father is convinced he's
going to be or he's going to be a
failure in life
or thomas edison just gets fired from
yet another job
and he's sort of drifting around
aimlessly and and what that really tells
you is a lot of life is persistence it's
hard work
and it's just when everything seems to
be in its lowest steps somehow leaders
find a way
or people who will become great figures
in history somehow find a way to
overcome it it's a real lesson in life
as much as anything else do you have a
favorite chapter
oh that's it you know
that's what i always ask the people who
read the book i say what's your favorite
chapter what's your part of the book
and and um more often than not my
favorite is different from other people
there are two chapters that i feel i
mean it's very hard for me to say which
i'm more attached to
i i love the chapter that has lee's
retreat
because just from a a standpoint of just
sheer drama and the craft of writing
i think it really sort of hums and
stores and it holds and grips the reader
and i also love the the prelude which i
have of april 1865 the introduction
most civil war books are more often not
they will start out with a more
traditional setting like the mexican war
i started out april 1865 and of all
places monticello with thomas jefferson
and the reason why i did that is because
i felt thomas jefferson a slave owner on
one hand
who also wrote the declaration of
independence a great
empire nation builder on one hand and
yet nobody was more of a fervent
believer in state rights
i sort of felt that jefferson seemed to
embody uh
the contradictions that would lead to
the civil war in in a way he was a
guiding spirit for both sides in the
civil war
and more interestingly when i went to
monticello i learned that you know on
the eve of april 1865
monticello it turns out had a northern
owner it had a southern owner and it was
cared for by neither
and that for me seemed to be a telling
metaphor for the country
now i should say getting back to the
craft of writing this book this was
probably the hardest thing to write in
the entirety of the book it had to be
rewritten several times
when the draft got to the publisher
thanks and good measure to the wonderful
sort of assistance of my wife in
extensive revision process
it was in pretty good shape but that was
one of the parts that really had to be
sort of redone and redone
and it wasn't clear to me how do i get
from here to there to make it work
finally it came out so i'm attached to
that one as well you talked about thomas
jefferson
there's one line here i want to ask you
about in 1800 do you write
he soberly warned that quote a single
consolidated government would become the
most corrupt government on earth
unquote why did you put that in there
and what do you think he'd think if he
saw things today
yeah yeah i'm not sure that's a snake
spit i totally want to walk into
you know the politics of back then don't
totally translate into the politics
today
but it is clear that jefferson davis who
was who was an agrarian who believed in
smaller government
local was better at every level
if one were to go back in time and sort
of tell him this is what the government
looks like
he would surely be appalled by it but
having said that i'm not sure that it
totally translates into today because
thomas jefferson is also somebody who
liberals love as well
so that's a partial answer so did you
meet characters in this book you want to
write more about
um you know er
most of them i would love to write more
about i'd love to write more about
robert e lee i'd love to write more
about thomas jefferson i'd love to read
more about u.s grant and abraham lincoln
you know one of the great things about
this book for me
as the author is um you know i was much
of the writing was taking place during
the whole monica lewinsky saga
and and everyone was talking about
leadership leadership where is
leadership and where is character and
this and that
i've got to say it was a great pleasure
every day to wake up and go to my desk
and deal with these figures who would
emerge larger than life and who would be
so critical in saving this country
so all of them i could easily see
writing about again i won't do it for
the next book though
you did though create a contrast between
william tecumseh sherman yeah and joe
johnston yeah
what role did they play in this after
april 1865 or
you know after the war we thought was
over and why did you compare the two
yeah yeah i compared the two because um
it just the contrast in their
personalities and their types
just invited comparison you know if you
think of
bill sherman bill sherman of course this
is bill sherman a union general
who who said war is hell and you cannot
refine it who took atlanta took savannah
who took colombia
and cut a swath 422 miles of the south
in which he sort of picked clean as he
put it
he was an asthmatic he was volatile he
was um
you know bill sherman is someone who i
like enormously i think he'd be great to
be at a dinner party with he would be
fascinating
he was a great intellect uh he spoke his
mind
um i sort of like what he said about
journalists although i'm not going to
say what he said
um well go ahead and repeat it uh it
basically was something to the effect of
of i'm close uh you know
he said god god damn those those
journalists that uh
that you know if if you died and went to
hell they'd still be there
i mean he really despised journalists in
fact he tried to imprison one and court
martial him
even though it didn't make any sense but
but sherman was just
he was a great military man but he was a
fascinating character you know in the
south today
and you know i've been on a 14 city book
tour and i've been all over the country
i've been east coast west coast in the
south
um sherman is is still reviled in much
of the south today but the irony is is
sherman said you know when this war is
over i will share with you my last
cracker the fact is
he actually loved the south it was his
love for the south that sort of led him
near the end to try to give
as generous as terms as possible now in
the case of joe johnson he was a kind of
prim
upright virginian um who
who um who was much more staid and much
more proper than sherman was
although the two of them had this
marionette dance in in sort of late 1864
in which they kind of chased each other
zigzag in fact johnson even inflicted
some serious blows at one battle against
against sherman and um and at one point
sherman banged on his dinner table he
says my god what is joe johnson's game
where
where is he today because he had escaped
from his grasp
and this is another example of two men
who became very close in life
as a result very close bonding as a
result of their war experiences
and you know it's so fascinating and
though i don't put this in the book when
sherman died
joe johnson was selected to be a
pallbearer at his funeral
and it was a cold misty rainy day and
and johnson didn't have a hat on and
somebody said to him he said well why
don't you put on a hat because it's it's
so cold and misty and of course
by then joe johnson's a very elderly man
and johnson straightens himself up and
says
well sherman would not do this for me
and i will do the same for him
and um joe johnson died something like
nine days later of pneumonia
now how did they end it what's the best
bennett house story yeah
the bennett house story is the story
that we never hear about appomattox is
is usually viewed as the end of the war
on april 9th
but of course as i was saying there's
still three confederate armies in the
field 175
thousand men davis calling for guerrilla
warfare five days later there's a
tripartite assassination attempt of
lincoln
uh andrew johnson and seward unions in
total chaos
and what takes place in bennett house in
north carolina
is the final surrender of the other
principal army of the confederacy
which is commanded by joe johnston and
and
it's a 10 days worth of negotiations
where john
sherman first sits down with johnston
and john breckenridge who was a former
vice president
and um and in breckenridge would join
him for the negotiations and at one
point
um the confederates will be laying down
such terms and and
sherman will move his chair back and say
well see here who's who's
surrendering to whom and um but in fact
sherman will give very generous terms
to the confederates and in doing so he
thinks he's carrying out lincoln's
vision
but he will be sharply rebuked by the by
the union cabinet particularly after the
death of of lincoln the assassination
and grant will actually be sent down to
talk to sherman
now this is a fascinating scene too
because in the union capital when this
happens
the attorney general james speed will
say well what if sherman decides to
arrest grant
and speed and stanton were convinced
that that sherman was potentially
thinking of some kind of a coup
and as they put it he was getting ready
to march northward with his allegiance
to take over
that's the kind of chaos and anarchy
that was gripping the north post
lincoln assassination while there's
still confederate armies in the field
so if johnson had decided to go to the
hills and along with lee to
sanction some kind of real warfare we
would have been in a real mess but
johnson instead followed lee's example
and and um and he too would surrender as
we said earlier in this act of basic
basically insubordination and in doing
so it would really
pave the way for this country to become
not like the balkans not like the middle
east
uh not like um webbing in our cambodia
or these other civil war torn countries
or northern ireland
but to become like america today so was
john wilkes booth working on his own
yeah that's a it's a great question and
it's one i don't know the answer to
very few issues did i duck in my own
mind when i went into this book whenever
i went into an issue i wanted to resolve
it in its entirety
that was something that i felt is really
beyond just the scope of the book on one
hand and for that matter the scope of my
own knowledge that's a lifetime's worth
of work
i my sense is he was not working in
concert
with the confederate government per se
but i also say in a footnote somewhere
in the endnotes that
that he may have had a relationship with
the confederate secret service
you know in our time we've known the cia
to have a number of rogue
operations which has been sanctioned by
sort of higher ups but not at the
highest levels
and something like that might have
happened with wilkes booth but
if there's one thing that i was struck
by with john wilkes booth
many historians kind of talk about this
kind of cockamamie rogue group that he
has
which is almost kind of pitiful in my
senses it's quite different
however sort of impromptu and improvised
this this
group that he assembled of assassins was
the fact of the matter is is
how close they almost came to
decapitating the entire union government
i mean that's really stunning did i read
in that footnote that you said that the
the secret service when the confederates
had something like 800 some thousand
dollars to
to do a project in the north yeah
i think that's probably right that's a
lot of money back then yeah
yeah but again as i'm gonna duck this
one that's i mean i know this from other
sources it is a lot of money
um but let's look at this in context we
do know that jefferson davis at another
point and this you know when when
sherman was ravaging the south a type of
warfare that robert e lee explicitly
rejected
attacking you know attacking innocents
and cities and and depopulating whole
state cities jefferson davis turned down
a proposal by his own men to send
smallpox infested blankets into the
north
so i don't think that the south is
willing to go that far
what's your next book uh my next book is
going to be as different and as kind of
bold and the sweeping as
as this book but on a very different
subject rather than write about
you know on one hand i'd love to write
about the civil war again because i have
a whole body of knowledge and it would
make my life a lot easier and certainly
my wife's life and my family life
but i want to be challenged i want to
write something different and if i feel
excited and enthused about it i'm
convinced i can make readers equally
enthused
so it'll probably be about the world of
the 1780s to 1790s
our guest is jay winnick here is the
book 1885 the month that saved america
thank you very much